the pennsylvania prosecutor in the bill
cosby sexual assault trial vows to retry
the case Judge Steven O'Neal declared a
mistrial on Saturday the jury said it
was quote hopelessly deadlocked after
deliberating for six days CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clement is here Ricky good
morning good morning this is not over
the story what happens what happens next
what happens next is the prosecution is
very determined to retry this case and
so is the accuser the alleged victim
Andrea constant what will happen is that
the judge has said that he would like to
go forward within 120 days the lawyers
will be brought to court they will have
a pre-trial conference there will be
motions filed they have one year by law
to prosecute this case again and we will
expect to see it and we will be back to
cover it
within a year other is it possibility to
other people might somehow try to get
another criminal case going against
Cosby no too late on what you have is
Andrea constant is the only alleged
victim whose case fell within the
statute of limitations which means that
it was not time barred by law and so
what you have is the prosecution is
going to go forward with this case on
these facts and they will attempt to try
the case as best they can which by the
way they did an excellent job the first
time the defense on the other hand is
going to be raising a number of motions
they will go forward to try to
relitigate everything that they have
relitigated in the past and they will
probably not be successful because judge
o'neal is going to have this case it is
assigned to him so I expect him to abide
by many of the same rulings that he is
already in including not allowing other
witnesses who have allegations against
Cosby to others to find this truck
especially not allowing other witnesses
what you have is this you have a number
of other accusers the prosecution wanted
to call 13 the judge allowed them to
call one in Kelly Johnson and you have
the same judge
so it would really not look to be very
judicious if suddenly judge O'Neal said
well this jury number one could not
reach a verdict by having one other so
now let's let the prosecution have
thirteen or two or three I don't expect
him to do that do we know what happened
in the jury room anybody come forward to
say this is the way it was not at this
time but one of the things about jury
deliberations that we have to understand
here this jury was out for a longer
period of time than the trial took to
take place so what you had is a jury
that was struggling in one way or
another we don't know if it was 11:00 to
1:00 or 6:00 to 6:00 but what we do know
is that there was an effort to persuade
one another the jury came back very very
early in the week asked saying that they
were hopelessly deadlocked what the
judge did is he read them something that
is called the Spencer charge in
Pennsylvania we know it as the dynamite
charge that's what we call it as lawyers
or it's called the Allen charge of many
places what that basically says is you
are the best jury that there is you
should really hold on to your views and
vote your conscience but you should try
to compromise defense lawyers hate that
charge and prosecutors love it rikki
Kleeman good evening to you as always